Speaker 1: All right, I've got something really
scary for you today. All right, I'm going to play
some video for you of a woman who could be could
be your child's teacher. Hopefully she's not,
but she could be a viewer who I won't name
sent me this video. This is from a teacher
in her school district who did a video on YouTube
called a lesson plan. And it wasn't a lesson plan.
It was an explanation of why this teacher, whose
name appears to be Kali Sue based on the YouTube
channel that this has been uploaded to. This is an
explanation of why this teacher wasn't in school.
It was a message to, I guess, her students. And
the reason she wasn't in school is because she
refused to get vaccinated or be tested for COVID.
She goes on in this video to spread all sorts of
disinformation about the vaccine viruses, masks.
We're going to look at a little bit and just
understand there are hundreds, thousands of people
like this who are teaching your kids right now
right now. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 5:
I everybody hope you're having a good day. I just
got done walking my my hands on this beautiful
Sunday, and I wanted to make a video because you
obviously can see that I'm not in class today,
right? And I want to go over a few things. One of
those things being explaining why I'm not there.
You deserve to know where the teacher is, please.
First thing is, I'm not sick. I'm not. I don't
have a cold, I don't have a sore throat. I feel
great. The reason that I'm not at school today
is because the administration has enforced the
jab mandate as well as if you refuse the jab,
then they're requiring testing and. I have
a strong. A very strong stance on that.
I feel. That it's unconstitutional. I guess.
Speaker 1: This is not a law professor, by the
way, and there's nothing unconstitutional,
so we're starting with. Remember,
this is a message to her students.
Speaker 5: Her ever, ever inject my body
with something that is experimental.
It doesn't qualify as a real. That's.
Speaker 1: So she's whispering
vaccine, remember, it is a vaccine,
and the Pfizer one has been FDA approved
Speaker 5: its gene therapy.
Speaker 1: It is not gene therapy.
Speaker 5: And if you asked any of them,
not one person would be able to
tell you what is in the shot.
Speaker 1: The truth is, the ingredients
are known. They are listed. Anybody can
google this now. She would probably
say, Well, the ingredient list is a
lie. But that's a different argument now.
Speaker 5: So I've done a lot of research,
Speaker 1: and there it is, there
it is the holy grail of spreading
disinformation. I've done research
Speaker 5: the past two years about
this and I knew it would get to this point
and I knew that I would make this decision.
I didn't know exactly how it was all
going to play out, but I just feel
really bad that you guys have to deal with it
firsthand. I feel horrible that you have to.
Speaker 1: The problem is that they're
having to deal with her. She's the problem.
Speaker 5: See this all play out
because it's it's painful and it's OK.
Speaker 1: So I'm going to skip forward
because later in this clip, I mean, there's a
lot of nonsense here. But then she goes into just
spreading straight up imaginary cuckoo stuff about
medical disinformation. Take a look at this
Speaker 5: oxygen actually kills the virus.
The right to breathe, the
right to make your own choices.
Speaker 1: I'm guessing this is anti-mask.
Oxygen kills the virus, so the mask is bad.
Speaker 5: It's a free country, or we thought it
was, but it's not. We have to fight for freedom,
and if you believe in freedom, if you believe
in living free, then you've got to do something
about it. You got to have some courage. You got
to step up and decide what you believe is right.
So just know that I'm praying for you
guys, I care about you so deeply and.
Stand strong. OK. Godwin's, and just
persevere. Finish strong. We're almost there.
Speaker 1: Can you imagine your kid
being taught in school by this woman?
And there's so much we can say. Obviously, there
are probably some parents who like this stuff,
OK? It seems like a dystopian nightmare
to me that this is the woman that might be
teaching our children. But there's another thing
I want to mention here with all of these people,
they all seem to have the idea. They don't
they don't seem to question that they might
have figured something out about COVID. That would
change the entire pandemic, that the entire global
medical community hasn't figured out. They did
their research on their home computer and have
figured things out that public health experts,
epidemiologists, immunologists, pulmonologists
around the world. Haven't figured out,
it's easy to call that merely delusional,
but it's it's really a form of incredible
arrogance in a sense, the the idea that
they may have done that now, discoveries happen,
discoveries happen and they come from different
places. But the idea that these folks are the
ones that by doing research, figured out, Hey.
All we got to do to get rid of COVID is don't
wear masks because oxygen kills the virus. So
just put oxygen on the virus, virus dies. You
don't need masks, you don't need a vaccine and
also throwing in God stuff, too as well. It is
delusional. It's dangerous to have these folks
teaching kids. But there's a level of arrogance
as well that they may have stumbled upon this,
and this is a major issue with social media.
Actually, this is I've mentioned before,
I'm almost done now reading the book Technopolis
by Neil Postman. You this is a must read book for
anyone participating in social media or news. I
think it's imperative everybody read it. There's
this reality that Neil Postman wrote about that
when you get a new technology. It's easy to say,
let's make sure it's only used in these ways,
but not in those ways. And the truth is,
once you've got the technology, the technology
changes the culture in irreversible ways.
One of the ways in which the internet high
speed internet internet on our phones and
social media have changed culture is that folks
who don't really know anything now are empowered
to do what they believe is research and to believe
their opinions about anything at all are just
as valid as those of actual experts. Now we've
talked about the crisis of expertize. This is not
this is not the fallacy of, you know, saying, if
someone's an expert, then if if the only reason
you trust someone is because they are claiming
expertize, then that's a fallacy. We're talking
about actual experts here, and this is one of the
seemingly irreversible impacts of widespread high
speed internet, mobile phones, smartphones and
social media. And this is really scary stuff. And
she's she's teaching people. She's teaching kids,
although maybe not much longer. I guess we'll see